is no such thing as clean brexit No Deal
breaks it's a different exit and a
different deal that would be needed
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constance in kissin and this is a show
for you if you're bored with watching
people argue on the internet over
subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our brilliant guest this week is an arch
remainer who we're very grateful to have
here Lord of Darkness welcome to
trigonometry thank you very much for
coming on the show let's get cracking we
usually ask our guests to tell us a
little bit about them but I think
everybody knows who you are and what you
stand for so we are where we are now in
this in this position we're having an
election or pretty much over this year
of brexit what just for anyone who
doesn't know exactly what your position
is what is your view of pressure do you
think it should be reversed do you think
we should have a second referendum to do
that what is your view I think it should
well let's hope it hasn't happened I
don't think it should happen and I don't
think it but I don't think it should
happen democratically and we're having
an election now and all the the parties
of the center and the left and about a
third of the conservative party if
people were actually able to express
their views inside that party don't want
it to happen and so what they want to
see happen is a referendum held with a
straight choice between Boris Johnson's
latest deal which is the second version
of the treaty for leaving the European
Union against remaining and what I'd
like to see happen I think is perfectly
credit what is what I think will happen
is that there will be a majority in the
next parliament against leaving on these
terrible terms as there was in the last
Parliament that since we can't
constantly just do nothing I mean
there's a limit to how long you can
literally tread water and not deal with
health education infrastructure well
there's other things which are of huge
concern to the country at this point
we'll have to bite the bullets biting
the bullet means calling a referendum
and that will probably be held next
spring
on the straight choice between the Boris
Johnson deal and staying in the European
Union and I think actually even if Boris
Johnson is Prime Minister on the 13th of
December since the most likely and
credible outcomes of the election it's
it's very very hard to see how the
Conservatives can win an overall
majority but it just possible it could
be the largest party in the next
parliament it's possible labour will be
the largest party the next Parliament
but if the concert is of the largest
party in the next parliament but don't
have a majority I still think that Boris
will end up with a referendum and I know
Boris Johnson quite well because when I
was transport secretary worked with him
closely as as Mayor of London I know him
well enough to know that he couldn't
give a fig about the European Union I
mean is the is equally was in favor of
staying poised in favor of leaving he
was in favor of being in the customs
union and the single market before he
was in favour of leaving them he's
perfectly capable of holding two
completely contradictory views at the
same time if the deal the only thing
he's really concerned about and has been
all the way through is becoming and
remaining prime minister and if the deal
for becoming and remaining prime
minister in in December and January is
it's moving towards a referendum on the
EU then I think that's what he'll do so
I'd it's at the moment it's all very
false because we're in a closely fought
election campaign and people think that
as they would do people to enter
catastrophize I think that the worst is
going to happen and that's there for the
game is over it's not remotely over at
the moment I would say we're roughly at
half time in this I mean this is gonna
be very reassuring room as the audience
who want to see us move on and all that
but I also were awfully halftime in this
great battle over membership of the
European Union and my best judgment at
the moment is that we're still end up
staying one final point about it is one
of the constant problems with leaving
the European Union is that whether
you're in favor or against leaving and I
respect that people hold different views
it's very very hard to do it's a hugely
complex thing so it's taking the egg out
of an omelet
it's nearly half a century worth of
diplomatic trade commercial legal
processes which have gone into our
relationship with the European Union but
not only is it very hard to do which is
what the government has found but it is
impossible to do
without self-harm because it goes to the
heart of our whole trading commercial
and security relationship with Europe
any move away particularly from free
trade which is an inevitable if we leave
the European Union is inevitably going
to involve harm and the reason why every
stage there's been a votes in the House
of Commons on it is that when MPs
true to their Berkey and principle of
being representatives and not just
delegates when they're actually faced
with a job of having to vote this thing
through which they know because they are
reasonably well-informed and they can
read the words on the page and see what
it means it's going to harm their
constituents there's always so far been
a decisive majority against it and my
view is that that will be the same in
the next part of this is the last before
we go any further can I just credit you
with an excellent use of the word fig it
was absolutely superb you realized it
was early in the morning you didn't drop
the f-bomb so congratulations on that
secondly before we go any further why
are you so opposed to leaving the EU
because the thing rep idli gets very
contentious you know Ramona you know
you're racist all these terms are
bandied about you know I think it's
really important for people to
understand why is it such a bad thing in
your opinion to me I've been in politics
for 30 years now and most issues in
politics are matters of degree then
they're not matters of fundamental right
or long or or huge a huge mistake that
you would make on behalf of the country
but about once a generation you get an
issue that's fundamental now most
fundamental issues in human affairs you
can recover from you know you can fight
a war and you can still recover from the
war but that doesn't mean it's
necessarily the right thing to do and
when you face up on these fundamental
issues the the thing in my experience to
do is fundamentally to oppose it and as
I look back over the last 150 years I
would say this is up there with the
three or four biggest mistakes that we
could have made as a country the two
others just to set them in the right
kind of context the the two biggest
mistakes we made as a country in the in
the in the century and a half before
this were not granting self-government
Ireland in the late 19th century which
was a catastrophic
mistake which was still recovering from
today and which in our generation and
indeed in the lives of many of those who
were here today was still was terrorism
on the streets of London
I live by Regents Park every day I
passed the bandstand when I go my walk
first thing in the morning in Regent's
Park which has a plaque to the 12 royal
green jackets who were who were killed
when a bomb exploded in the middle of
the afternoon concert on a Saturday
afternoon by the IRA that is a direct
consequence of us not getting policy on
Ireland right in the 19th century and we
had an opportunity under Gladstone to
create a self-governing Ireland within
the United Kingdom and if we done it
then we wouldn't have had all these
terrible consequences which blighted so
much of the $0.20 we got that wrong the
other big mistake we got wrong a
catastrophic mistake was going into the
First World War which everybody thought
would be one of those short wars that
will be over by Christmas and ended up
as a massive configuration which then
caused the Second World War
what was essentially a civil war in
Europe for 30 years now so let me just
let me just pause you there because you
talk about the fundamental issues but
Francis and I both voted remain on a
referendum but isn't the fundamental
issue here democracy you know I grew up
in Russia in the Soviet Union where we
didn't have it and when I see a vote
that went through I didn't vote to leave
but most people did isn't the
fundamental issue here respecting the
wishes of the people even if as you say
and I may take I may not some people
think that it would be damaging to their
constituents but have we not had a
parliament that actually doesn't
represent the wishes of the people well
the people can't betray the people that
is a fundamental principle of democracy
and democracy is not about one vote at
one moment and there no votes ever again
that is generally speaking however I'm
not I'm not saying I'm opposed to the
second world what I'm saying is without
temperature and the results of the first
no but that is the answer to your point
the answer to your point is this whole
business serve breaks it is itself for
process when we had the referendum three
and a half years ago people couldn't
know what brexit would mean not because
they were stupid or because they were
ill-informed but because there was no
proposal on the table the only proposal
for brexit on the table three and a half
years ago was forwards on the ballot
paper leave the European Union there was
no plan behind it there was no agreement
even amongst the people in favor of
brexit as thought it should mean some
that
compatible with staying in the single
market in the customs union including
the prime minister at the moment who
said so in the referendum campaign other
people said that we should leave some
people said that we would maintain
freedom of movement which is fundamental
to the whole concept of the European
Union where the people can travel freely
across borders or not other people said
that we couldn't as that has come to be
worked through and as it has remained
deeply controversial within our
democracy the right thing to do was as I
still believe we will will to hold a
further referendum chickens are
questions on that then be given that we
voted to leave either we leave on the
withdrawal agreement the Boris Johnson's
negotiated or we leave with no deal and
those should be the job but obviously
not because the the the the majority of
people according to opinion surveys and
majority of MPs are actually in favor of
staying in the European Union but we had
over surrender already but again we
couldn't judge staying in the European
Union against a specific deal where's
this time we can and the right thing to
do I mean what why would you want to
constrain the options you're putting to
people when there's by far the most
popular option out there is one that's
absolutely credible which is staying in
the European Union so I completely agree
with you
this is a fundamental democratic minute
but the fundamental difference between
the European Union and the Soviet Union
which you referred to is one is a
democracy and one is not you know when
always forget all these phone
secretaries I come and go so far there
was one called Huntz wasn't there
recently he's now so receded into the
distance
when he in trying to curry favor a
Conservative Party conference likened
the European Union to the Soviet Union
Donald Tusk the president of the
European Union who was a solidarity
activists in the 1980s against the
Soviet Union made the fundamental point
that there was a difference between an
empire and a democracy and it's because
the European Union is a democracy that
is proved to be it's a club of
democracies is 28 democracies it's a
club of them it's because it's proved to
be so viable and so successful that that
we should be staying in it and not
leaving it and so we talked about brexit
and we're getting you know talk about
leaving but what are the implications
for the ordinary working person on the
street how will it impact them how and
most importantly how will it impact the
economy well somebody in when we were
having our warm-up before while we're
waiting for Constantine to
bringing that up a formal transport
secretary cuz when I was doing transport
whatever new you can transport is before
and after Chris Grayling Hispanic but
when we were doing our warm-up somebody
said it'll take ten or fifteen years to
recover from this either way well it
will take more than ten or fifteen years
to negotiate and to try and make stable
leaving the European Union and that's
accepted by everybody because the the
the the formal act of leaving which is
what we could do in the next few months
that simply begins a huge process of
negotiations over trade deals security
pacts political relationships with the
European Union and so on which will be
at least ten years just in pure
negotiations and probably more and since
my judgement is and all I can give
people as my judgment is it won't be
stable and it will lead to loss of jobs
to weakness international weakness and
possibly very serious weakness visa not
least visa vie putin's and post putin's
russia i I think what will happen in ten
to fifteen years as we go through this
process the next generation of
politicians will put membership of the
European Union back on the table in a
serious way so I think that is deeply
unstable and is a recipe for the next
generation having to be overwhelmed by
this issue of Europe however if we stay
in the European Union nothing changes
nothing changes at all it's not to say
that there won't be some resentment
there probably be 10 15 percent who will
who will think that we should continue
to campaign for leaving but can I give
you a prediction if we stay because of
course it doesn't require any further
negotiations at all if we stay we're
still members we continue on exactly the
same terms the whole thing goes away if
we stay my prediction is that no Prime
Minister in the net in the lifetime of
anyone here whether their labor
conservative libbed some new party
that's created is ever going to call
another referendum on Britain's
membership the Open Union people will
look back on the Cameron may Johnson
experience and they would say this is
the third rail of British politics you
touch it and you're dead so we will not
go there again we've had a lot of
remainders on the show we've had a lot
of experts who are brexit ears on the
show but one thing
they would say is that you're misjudging
very badly the mood of the public in the
country in terms of how strongly people
feel about leaving and equally how
little they care about the economic
impact a lot of people are quite
comfortable losing out some of the polls
in the last couple years showed that
over three-quarters of levers would be
happy to lose out financially for ment
for example controlling immigration so
if everything stays the same the mood
and the public will continue to sour I
would put it - well unusually I'm I've
been for people expressing views on this
I've actually been speaking to the
public a lot directly about it I've done
I've done nearly two hundred meetings up
and down the country campaigning on
brexit most of them in leave areas over
the course of the last year and a half
so I've met a very large number of
people who've been affected by and I've
been to all other communities I know
these community as well - so I'm a
former school's mister and transport
minister and in both of those jobs I
travelled the length and breadth of the
country and I know these communities in
fine in fine in fairly fine detail and
what's clear to me from all of that
experience is that in leave areas there
there is a group of people who are
politically active who are passionate
about leave and that's clearly the case
I would put that at 10 to 15 percent of
the electorate in all these cases in
Romania's it's much lower than that
however the reason why there was a vote
of 52% which in those communities was in
some cases 55 60 65 % wasn't to do with
leaving the European Union it was to do
with misgovernment at home the
combination of austerity no proper plan
for jobs and Community Renewal in these
areas deep poverty and a deep sense of
alienation from their own government
which is predominantly an issue to do
with London Westminster and the quality
of representation within the UK not to
do with the European Union so where I
agree with you is if the deal is stay
and do nothing
we will go round and round in circles on
this issue and it could well come up
again in the form of brick suits we
can't do that it's you know one of my
friends here in the audience when we
were warming up before described himself
as a socialist and said I wasn't that
sure I am a socialist I do believe in
radical social change and I believe in
creating much much stronger a much
stronger state and social institutions
partly to deal with this biggest soot of
alienation inequality and poverty which
bedevils our society so what we actually
need is to remain and reform and the
reform should be fundamental and it's
the reason why I'm on the left and not
the right in politics is what we should
be doing is remain and a reforming
government like the Atlee governments of
1945 which set up the welfare state set
up the NHS invested in our public
services in a big way that's what we
need and what led to Brick's it was this
really toxic combination of brexit plus
austerity with the government calling
the referendum three and a half years
ago being a Conservative government with
Cameron Osborne that was actually itself
the agents of austerity which particular
in areas that voted leave which tended
to be the poorer parts of the country
these became the same thing in people's
mind the European Union and austerity
what we've gots to do is to break that
connection
and that's partly of campaigning issue
making it clear that you don't have to
have a EU and austerity but it's also a
question of policy what we need to do is
to remain and at the same time dramatic
reform to invest in our public services
end austerity take power much closer to
people because England is one of the
most centrally governed large nations in
the world which particularly in areas
more distant from London is deeply
resented it's different in Scotland
Wales and Northern Ireland where they
have to evolve dissemble is very telling
Lee in the case of Scotland and Northern
Ireland they voted heavily against a
brexit so it needs a big new policy
offer and that's what's also at stake in
this general election and we're going to
touch on no deal for a second because I
think and I consider myself politically
aware but there's a lot of people you
know they're going about their day and
you know they're trying to make it
through the week they've got families
and they hear terms like No Deal or you
know you know in Norway agreement all
the rest of it what is a No Deal breaks
it and how will that impact on the lives
of ordinary people
it's afford the use of the word no do
what cuz what the No Deal mean it means
no Treaty of any kind must with know'd
word no means none no agreement with the
European Union at all
now there's virtually no one who says
they support No Deal that actually
supports that no when we debate as I
have done for hundreds of hours now in
Parliament's the different options on
brexit
those on the rights of the Conservative
Party the Ian Duncan Smith's
and all that lot plus the bricks that
people don't actually support no deal at
all because if there's no deal at all
planes don't fly you put the ports don't
operate nowhere to leave and come into
the country because all of those
arrangements are governed by deals
they're governed by treaty what they're
talking about actually isn't no deal
it's a different deal it's a deal that's
much more limited that doesn't involve a
customs arrangements arrangements over
the transition of of goods which are
tariff free and things or arrangements
for international driving licenses a
whole lot of things it might not cover
but it must cover a whole set of quite
important and complex issues like the
operation of the ports the international
aviation system which is governed by
treaties which we're part of because
we're part of the European Union all of
those things will be necessary and those
Boris Johnson Michael Gove all these
people are actually negotiating brexit
when they talk about No Deal they still
accept that we're going to need to deal
covering all those things so it's there
is no such thing as clean brexit No Deal
breaks it's a different brexit and a
different deal that would be needed and
what that is is what we will get into
debating if there happens to be an
overall conservative majority but I
guess Frances question is if we were to
have that kind of deal what would be the
impact why is it so bad why is it so
scary what's the problem with that kind
of deal well nobody knows what that deal
is because no one's set it out at the
moment I mean we're looking we're
peering into as you know as the Good
Book says peering into a glass darkly we
don't know because no one has set it out
the reason they won't set it out is
because it is almost all of the elements
would be very bad so for example if they
don't involve a trade deal one of my
friends and the audience said before
that we had enough of this we should
walk away start negotiating off words if
there is no trade deal you are
immediately facing tariffs on British
goods going to our largest markets the
in the European Union and vice-versa
between ten and a hundred and fifty
percent over none aids that happens
overnight you are faced with customs
declarations and customs forms costing
between fifty and a hundred pounds
apiece
which people would have to start filling
in immediately I mean these are the this
is this is not you know it seems as if
you can do it in its cost-free until it
happens the point at which it happens I
can assure you as a parliamentarian
there will be a huge and dramatic change
in opinion and that's before you get to
the issue of islands because no deal an
island means immediately there have to
be
border arrangements between Republic of
Ireland and Northern Ireland which
breaks the Good Friday Agreement the
Good Friday Agreement is not only an
international treaty but it's the
bedrock of of peace in in Northern
Ireland which only a generation ago we
didn't have so I don't know deal has not
been defined if it were defined most
people who look at this actually
understand what's gonna happen would
find it horrific and even people who
glibly and it's very easy to be very
glib and populist and so it's all going
to be fine
you know it's Dunkirk and all that the
moment it actually happens there will be
a massive social revolt it doesn't
matter whether it's Boris Johnson
whether it's Nigel Faraj whether it's
Jeremy Corbyn in number ten they will
have to sort it out PDQ and I'm been in
politics long enough to know that even
if people voted for something which
turns out to be a catastrophe
they don't somehow think that oh that's
all work we voted for it they expect the
people who are there who are in charge
to sort it out and in particular they
will start saying that they were lied to
because the people who say that no deal
is going to be fine we can whether it's
Dunkirk and all of that when it is not
fine when that prices go up in the shops
by 10 to 50 percent when there's a big
shortage of goods when bombs start going
off in Northern Ireland they will not
say oh well we voted for this they will
say we were lied to it now needs to be
sorted out and you began by saying why
do I think this is such a big issue this
is a colossal issue this goes to almost
everything that matters to us as a
political community whether we can
actually get terms of trade relations a
system in Northern Ireland that works
all of these things have been very
elaborately and painstakingly put
together over the last or 70 years now
since the European Union started in the
ashes of the Second World War and we
shouldn't throw it all up in a fit of
absence of mind and we've just touched
on Northern Ireland and I've got a lot
of friends from Northern Ireland and
they are absolutely enraged with what is
happening and
particular they feel that the arrogance
with which the English have treated them
if brexit happens do you think we're
gonna see a return to the bad old times
well it depends what breaks it happens
if the if brexit were to happen
according to Boris Johnson's latest deal
nothing changes in on Ireland because
the deal which is part of isn't quite so
controversial with the brexit party and
the right wing of the Conservative Party
is it breaks it happens according to
Boris Johnson's later steel the Northern
Ireland rather like Hong Kong becomes
one country two systems'
because what happens in Northern Ireland
under Boris Johnson's own deal is that
European law continues to apply the
Northern Ireland continues to be part of
the customs union in the single markets
all intents and purposes it's slightly
it's slightly gilded in the deal by
saying it would still be part of the
United Kingdom customs union but in fact
actually they'll need to be customs
declarations down the Irish Sea and all
of that because Northern Ireland will
continue to operate according to the
treaty all of the trade and economic
terms and conditions of membership of
the European Union so that you don't
have to have a border between the
Republic of Ireland and Northern Ireland
but that won't apply between Northern
Ireland and Great Britain
so for Northern Ireland itself it is to
do I think the the Boris Johnson deal
would lead to a term the troubles now I
don't because to all intents and
purposes Northern Line remains part of
the European Union I do think though and
this is could be a course of problems
down the line is it we'll put on the
table in a big way the issue of the
creation of a single Irish States
because if you've got one country two
systems and most of the economic and
commercial and immigration rules which
is a large part of public policy which
govern Northern Ireland are set by the
European Union by the consent of
Northern Ireland's they would prefer to
have happen rather than have a hard
border in Ireland if that happens you do
then quite quickly get to the question
well why why remain part of the United
Kingdom I mean it's very it becomes an
existential question quite quickly so my
view is that if the Boers johnson deal
goes through it's only a matter of time
and probably quite a short period of
time before they'll be a referendum in
northern ireland about creating a single
Irish state now I don't welcome that
it's not because I my view of Northern
Ireland is that the people of Northern
Ireland should decide what
I don't take the same view of Ascot them
I think will be a catastrophic mistake
for Scotland's become independent
because we all share one island together
the arguments are different tonight
what I do worry about for my own because
I'm a historian and concede the long
view on this and also I go to Northern
Ireland a lot is that in Northern
Ireland majorities aren't enough that's
what the genius of the Good Friday
Agreement
is that whereas most of politics is
governed by simple majorities where you
have a fundamental nationalist unionist
cleavage without a basis of shared
consent between the two if you try to
make these big existential questions to
decide them by simple majorities that is
what leads to violence conflict and
terrorism is what did lead to violence
conflicts and terrorism two generations
ago so what really worries me is if we
make this issue of the creation of an
Irish state if it were to become a
majority view it nor deny its been a
minority of you up till now but if it
would become a majority view that is not
enough because the unionist community in
northern island is not gonna say hey
there's now fifty five sixty percent
that who are in favor of created the
United Island so we're going to go along
with it I can tell you if you meet guys
like Sammy Wilson and Nigel Dodds and
Eileen foster they are not somehow gonna
say oh that's all hunky dory we've now
got a majority for United I'm we go
along with it what you will get is the
the breakout of really extreme unionist
politics which will lead to paramilitary
activity and all of that so the best
thing to do the best thing to do in
Northern Ireland as in my mind in the
whole of the United Kingdom in relation
to brexit is simply not to do it simply
not to do it at all will you be better
off we would avoid a massive national
car crash by doing it and that is also
true of Northern Ireland though there
won't be an immediate crisis because
Boris Johnson's deal essentially keeps
Northern Ireland both in the United
Kingdom and in the European Union well
other than the Northern Ireland issue
what is what are your concerns with
Boris Johnson's deal well why why won't
you accept that as the Democratic will
of the people implemented through a
compromise in that way well if it was
the Democratic will of the people we had
a referendum of course I would accept it
but why is it that my strong advice to
people in this election and in a
referendum would be not to do it
is that not only is it worse than the
status quo because it removes us from
our main trading bloc our security is
all based on a very close and intimate
relations we but that is what people
voted for to be removed from the failing
but withholding we're going around in
circles I'm saying it should be after an
election and another referendum so if
they vote for it then I would accept it
but why is it my advice is that they
shouldn't do it is that it would both be
worse and it's also a leap into the
unknown and that a crucial thing to
understand about the Boris Johnson deal
is that it doesn't actually have any
deal beyond the end of what's called an
implementation period which is at the
end of next year at the end of 2020 the
only deal in relation to our whole
commercial trade economic and security
policy Vasavi the European Union the
only deal in this five hundred page
document the only deal is to agree a
transition which is till the end of next
year can be extended by two further
years during which we will negotiate to
the actual deal I mean just think about
that for a moment is it sensible just as
a matter of general precaution not
leaping into the unknowns who you know
where you're going is it sensible to
give up all of that whether your leave
or remain to give up all of the known
benefits of remain the known benefits of
being in the European Union for an
intermediate status where you have no
idea what's going to happen afterwards
surely the right thing to do which is by
the way what we were also promised in
the referendum three and a half years
ago is not to take this huge decisive
step of leaving the European Union and
said you know what your long-term
relationship with the European Union is
going to be now we talked a lot of
moments ago about Northern Ireland's the
reason why this document is 500 pages
which is a legal treaty about 400 pages
of that are to do with Ireland because
in the case of Ireland because of the
Good Friday Agreement it wasn't the
European Union and indeed to be fair the
British government didn't think it was
sensible or indeed even safe to agree to
an arrangement in respect of Ireland
that expired at the end of next year
because they thought that was too
dangerous that is the reason why we had
the backstop oh now I've got the
permanent set of relations what's
essentially happened is that they're
been tuned
negotiations one is a long-term
agreement about the status of Northern
Ireland which is that all intensive
purposes Northern Ireland remain in the
European Union but only a very
short-term deal in respect to Great
Britain which expires at the end of next
year or maybe is renewable for another
two years after that during which period
all of the long-term relationship will
be negotiated now the right thing to do
if this you were buying a house on this
basis and or doing any other personal do
you absolutely would not agree to giving
up you know moving house and going into
temporary accommodation until you could
see where you're going to be moving
thereafter and that is the bed the roots
of the arguments against Boris Johnson's
deal and Lord Adonis you describe
yourself as associates and we've got
socialists in or credit to you've done a
wonderful job in Venezuela well done
great stuff my well II supports them so
yeah he does okay so I think that's
called guilt by association is there
have you know on that basis on that
basis General Pinochet and what was
Johnson of all part of the same
political family as well it doesn't
quite work see France is pissing
everyone was a joke but no he's never
denounced a Venezuelan government but
anyway we're moving on that's not the
point the point is is so you described
you so socialist we've got socialists in
the room there are lots of people on the
left of the Labour Party who said that
you can't be truly socialist unless you
support brexit because so true socialism
will never happen under the European
Union do you ascribe to that notion
there aren't lots there very few most of
the left of the Labour Party are in
favor of staying in the European Union
this organization called momentum which
is the one that was set up in the wake
of jeremy corbyn's victory and all of
that the great majority of momentum
activist and did a lot and come to my
meetings I know these meetings I was
talking about earlier Oh in favour of
staying in the European Union and a lot
of them passionately in favor of saying
the former chief executive of momentum
is an ardent pro-european campaigner
Dean do you know her very well she has
an Italian husband
she's got relations across the European
Union she's sort of a classic product as
I'm as am i you know my dad has Cypriots
I came a generation ago that I can
assure you all of these communities in
which of
very strong in London but of course a
present across the United Kingdom are
passionately against in my community
thus it becomes you will literally be
divided by bricks it I'll have a whole
load of relations who won't be to come
in and out of the country until we know
what the long-term deal is and whether
it involves visas and all of that so the
situation is is is as it is on the left
it is of overwhelming opposition to
brexit there is a small group who have
this view that you can't do some forms
of nationalization inside the European
Union actually because I'm pragmatic
there's no evidence that that's true
most of our European partners have
larger nationalized sectors than we have
cuz they didn't go through the
Thatcherite period France you know
transports my particular area France
Germany Italy Spain the Netherlands
Belgium all these countries still have
state railway companies most of their
railways are still run by state
companies indeed the irony is a lot of
those state companies have been bidding
for contracts to run railways here in
order to extract some of the profit from
the way that we privatized our railways
under the Tories 20 years ago so being
pragmatic and by the way have have
state-owned water and electricity
companies as well which we don't have at
the moment and they do all of that
within the European Union so whilst it
is true that there is a requirement to
put contracts out to Tendo and things of
that kind which actually I supports I
think you should always see what choices
are available of course most of you up
they have much larger nationalized
sectors than we have in the utilities
which is the main area of debate inside
this general election in the utilities
they mostly on the constant have
state-run not privately run enterprises
that's absolutely compatible with
membership of the European Union and
that's the reason why most people on the
Left don't have a problem with EU
membership
[Music]
so on the subject of the left and the
Labour Party it seems to me we mentioned
hit Jeremy Corbyn briefly that always
ends up well I I voted for the Labour
Party the last election and it was the
first election I believe in recent times
when more working-class people voted for
the Conservative Party than did for the
Labour Party there there there is a lot
of resentment among working-class people
about the Labour Party becoming the
party of the kind of metropolitan
university educated early Jeremy Corbyn
shall we be charitable to say he's been
unclear about his position on brexit
what do you make of the the Labour Party
in in an breaks in the current time well
all political parties or social
coalition's and that's right because
they a aim of politics and democracy is
to bring people together and to try and
create consensus not to divide them so
I'm proud of the fact that there's a
strong middle-class component in the
labour party and of course a strong
trade union and and working-class
component what the job of the party is
for you know a possibility the People's
Party is to bring people together do I
think we have strong enough social
support clearly not I mean somebody said
before that's that we defied the polls
in the last election well we did do a
lot better by the end of the election at
the beginning but it's very important
that my labour friends understand that
we've lost the last election we didn't
win it we had 55 fewer seats than the
Conservatives at the end of the last
election campaign and we pulled two and
a half percentage points less than the
Conservatives which by historic
standards is about the division between
winning and losing parties historically
what we did in the last election was to
achieve it was to it was to turn
catastrophe into an arrow defeats what
we've got to do this time is to turn our
defeat into victory and what does that
require it requires as it always does in
politics having a broad social and
political appeal and that means we've
got have a very strong appeal in
working-class communities where all this
has we've been talking about earlier
disaffection extreme poverty extreme
inequality the absence in many of these
communities of a real plan for jobs and
Community Renewal we get all of that
right - but if you're sitting in a
morass
and part of London for example at the
moment we're leaving European Union is
also existential you know what's going
to happen to that you know the London is
is a city which has 15 universities it
has one of the most international higher
education sectors in the world possibly
in the world all of that is in jeopardy
all of it is in jeopardy with brexit so
we need to be able to bring together all
of these different parts of the
community and to speak to them all and
it's perfectly compatible
it is absolutely compatible to be able
to say in Middlesbrough we need a really
big plan for jobs investments and
dealing with poverty Middlesbrough us at
the same time saying in parts of London
we don't want brexit because we don't
want to be having visas required for
people to travel between Britain and the
constant these aren't incompatible
policies we need to be very strong in
saying all of them and building a broad
social coalition and I believe it's
possible for us to do that but my point
is Jeremy Corbyn hasn't done that he
hasn't done that I know a lot of
working-class people who feel utterly
alienated by his position on many issues
and his lack of clarity on the issue of
brexit I know many metropolitan liberal
types who are deeply alienated who voted
labour entire life because the position
on breccia has been so muddled so
unclear and a lot of people feel that is
actually dishonest he's tried to play
both sides and he's got none to be fair
I've been probably as you cranly said at
the beginning one of the the more active
remain campaigners but nationally and
inside the Labour Party I made myself a
awkward with the current labour
leadership including Jeremy personally
by campaigning really hard last year in
the party for us having a second
referendum at a stage when the party
didn't when he didn't want didn't want
to commit one and at the party
conference last year that was the big
issue was whether we would commit to
holding a second referendum with the
remain option that is now party policy
that is at the heart of our manifesto
for this for this election now I I don't
myself believe in thought police
politics I don't believe that you it is
incompatible to be a member of the
Labour Party and to be a brick so I
think it's perfectly possible we
discussed it earlier to be labour and to
be in favor of brexit I certainly don't
think we should have some kind of
doctrinaire test to be a member of the
Labour Party we have to be a remainer
I do think is right what I've been
campaigning for is that we should give
the country the choice which also means
giving Labor Party activists the ability
to campaign for people to have the
choice and Jeremy has committed to that
so what I was seeking to do all of last
year which that we should be committed
to a second referendum with a remain
option and on the back of that we should
have a big reform plan for the country
that is the party's manifesto in this
election I am certainly not going to be
out there saying and therefore every
Labour Party member must sign in blood
that they are remain there that's not my
kind of politics at all so you're saying
that it's about essentially labour
winning hearts and minds my question to
you would be how is labour in particular
Jeremy Corbyn going to be able to do
that when he can't even unite his own
party well we see people defecting well
actually that's simply not true look the
fact is because sometimes because of the
way our rather Tory media reports things
and the BBC was meeting a great job you
would think that there was right and
rebellion inside the Labour Party large
numbers of labour and piece of beans to
deselect and do you know how many labour
members of parliament have actually been
deselected for this election I think the
Frances was referring to your believing
I'll come to them in a moment
hold on the answer is none none not a
single labour member of parliament has
been affected do you know how many
conservatives have been deselected as
they've imposed their extreme grexit
option on well it was 21
of whom 10 have now been readmitted but
it's significantly more what all of the
things which the right claimed that the
left had been doing which is intolerance
not allowing broad spectrum of opinion
or that they've been doing to themselves
now it's true a few Labour MPs have left
it's a handful who left it's chucker
it's chrysalis time it's literally it's
a handful this year and aperture it but
far more conservatives have left you
know I was doing a thing two days ago
with Dominic grieve dominic grieve who
is by the way I think has played an
absolute blinder in not in terms of
parliamentarians I have a real respect
for who doing the Burke's job of being
representatives not delegates saying the
right thing for the country and doing
all of that he's up there he is having
to fight in beckons field at the moment
as an independent because he's been
expelled from the Conservative Party so
I don't I don't think
label party bus I need any lessons and
intolerance from people in in other
political parties or or commentators
when the real intolerance we're facing
in British politics at the moment which
is deep and bitter intolerance is on the
rights with Faraj and the brexit party
and a Conservative Party more
intolerance of divergent views than any
time in my lifetime
whereas Joey Corbin actually has
maintained the Labour Party as a broad
Church he himself of course has a very
clear view where he is personally but he
has not been you know I mean I don't
mind describing myself as historically a
Blair right I think that the Blair
governments are the best things that's
happened to this country particular
what's happened since I mean let's bring
back Teddy Blair I mean let's have a lot
more of that rather than what we've had
since the country believe the Blair is
inside the Labour Party are
overwhelmingly still inside the Labour
Party yeah and I have no hesitation in
saying that what we want is a broad
church Labour Party I'm content with
Jeremy corncob is leadership in the
selection provided he operates a broad
church policy and as we've discussed on
Europe which has been the most
contentious issue inside the party he's
in fact compared to how the last three
leaders of the Conservative Party have
played it he has been God's gift to
broad-mindedness tolerance and pluralism
in politics anyway so what would you say
to people so off the top of my head
people like Philip Collins who you know
you will know well used to write
speeches bless main speech writer
comedian Matt Ford you know people who
were staunch labour people and felt that
the party was moving in a direction that
was unacceptable and they had to
renounce their membership and in Philips
Collins case observe anti-semitism well
I think that they were mistaken in terms
of leaving the party do I do I think
that there's a problem of anti-semitism
inside the labour party I think there is
why why is there a problem because there
were some members of the party who had
been tolerant of anti-semitic views and
anti-semite my own
view is very straightforward just that
those people have no part in any
mainstream political party and that
includes the Labour Party and that has
come under the spotlight and there is a
equalities and human rights
investigation into whether the party has
handled that properly and I think anyone
who's been responsible for tolerating or
excusing or allowing anti-semites to
play a role inside the party I think
that is a fundamental issue and it needs
to be to be sorted out but do I think
that we should all all those of us who
don't hold those views which is the
overwhelming majority of people inside
the Labour Party Labour MPs labour
members labour members of the House of
Lords like myself do we think we should
therefore leave our own party I think
that's a category error I think it's the
anti-semites and those who hold those
views should be leaving the party but
it's not those of us who hold the main
that sense that they have left the party
as you say they have been tolerated and
it seems to be that the people who are
leaving feel like it's either them
leaving or staying in a party where
those anti-semites are allowed to remain
so so I think that's a category error
the the anti-semites are the tiny
majority those of us who who don't hold
those views and find them repugnant are
the overwhelming majority and in any
organisation it shouldn't be the
overwhelming majority that have to leave
their party because my point was
something else which is those people who
are leaving feel like the the party
leadership is not addressing that issue
robustly enough would you agree with
that I think it wasn't addressing it
robust you know I think it is now is my
view in response I think in and at the
time and you know some of the people you
mentioned a friends of mine I completely
respect their points of view but is
always been my view of politics that you
should stay and fight and you certainly
don't leave until you've lost and on
this issue of anti-semitism we haven't
lost and the country the overwhelming
majority of people who hold these views
who hold our views which is that we find
it completely repugnant unacceptable
we're the ones who've come through and
to give a specific example Margaret
Hodge who was absolutely in the in the
lead on these issues is fighting the
next election as the Labour candidate in
Barking and Dagenham and she as you know
as being was extremely critical of
leadership Lily
for these issues so I understand what
they're saying but we're the majority
they're the minority and it should be
the minority which in the case of
anti-semitism is a tiny minority should
be them that leave the party it
shouldn't be the rest of us and do you
think Corbin and his leadership has
condoned anti-semitism well that's a
matter for the European for the
equalities and human rights
investigation I don't know very critical
answer the truth is I don't know that's
the reason why if people have condoned
it there is totally unacceptable okay
not a slightest hesitation
okay before we crack on with questions
can we just thank lot of donors for the
given assist time and coming out whether
we agree with everything or not so a
gentleman there please
thank you and we'll go there and we'll
go there we'll take three at a time and
then get some answers Thanks thanks for
interesting discussion I'm about a
second referendum um I agree with Lord
onus that if a clear majority of the
public now wants to remain it would be
kind of crazy to go to fly in the face
of that but does he not accept that
every election every referendum involves
a large turkey a chance depend on the
weather dependent last-minute political
event it depends on the charisma of the
people involved and if a second
referendum happens and it's 52 48 the
other way it's not gonna feel like the
country has changed its mind it's gonna
feel like the coins been flipped until
the answer remain as one is provided so
where'd he be prepared to require a 2/3
supermajority for a second referendum if
the first one's going to be overturned
and that would close the door to further
referendums no is the answer because
because we have to we have to make a
decision and so though I would hope much
rather it was a bigger majority than
that the fact of the matter is we've got
to decide and if we start putting
artificial things rules in like that
what happens if we get into the zombie
situation where there's a majority but
it doesn't meet the super majority what
do you then do do you go and adopt the
minority position because even got the
majority position so though as it
happens I would have supported a larger
majority for the first referendum for
you started this process
we have now got to decide and I think it
was very dangerous to put artificial
majorities in that could mean we're in a
kind of zombie land where we're
incapable of acting as a country and in
the situation we're now in we can't not
act it's very important to understand
that we're in a very different situation
from three and a half years ago three
and a half years ago we didn't need to
start this process so if you hadn't
reached your supermajority wouldn't have
mattered you just don't start the
process of leaving the EU now we are
about to leave 31st of January we're
leaving so if you have a zombie
situation where you have a majority but
it's not the supermajority what do you
do do you leave or not leave so though I
would would have agreed with you from
the beginning of the process not to
start the process without it we are in a
desperate crisis situation at the moment
we've got to decide as a country and I
would not put any impediments in the way
of being able to decide and
unfortunately a supermajority could be
just such an impediment at the moment I
do agree with you of course there are
lots of chance factors in elections that
oh the 3rd referendum the third crucial
thing to understand about our system is
that what we've got which is part of the
reason we're in a situation at the
moment is we have what is basically a
parliamentary democracy which is now
over the course of the last 50 years
we've grafted certain elements of direct
democracy on through it's now you could
have a debate about whether that was a
good idea or not a good idea whether
it's good to have referendums at all but
under our system of government is
fundamentally different from for example
Switzerland referendums are only held
because Parliament calls them the only
reason there was a referendum three and
a half years ago scuzz David Cameron and
the majority in parliament called it we
don't have the initiative which they
have in Switzerland which enables the
people themselves to call referendums
which is the reason why they have five
to ten referendums a year now one thing
I am pretty sure of is that if after
this second referendum there is not
going to be a third referendum in any
hurry because you won't get a
parliamentary majority and a prime
ministers prepared to call it so we're
not in a situation where you end up with
never endings because always a minority
in the country can call it under our
system only a parliamentary majority by
statute can call a referendum and that
requires essentially the leadership of
the governing party which means the
Prime Minister to agree and as I say
after a second referendum I can't see
any Prime Minister
in the short-term agreeing for to
another referendum on leaving the
European Union if we do leave actually
think there was a reasonable chance that
the Prime Minister in 10 or 15 years
might call a referendum on going back in
but but that's another matter without a
question at the back there somebody had
their hand up I saw you first yeah I
thank you it was really interesting
discussion um there are a couple of
things that you've said I'd like to
tease out to get you to elucidate a
little further on the first thing was
you talked about us being approaching
the half-time stage in the brexit debate
I'd really appreciate some clarity when
exactly you think the kickoff whistle
was was it 2016 was it in 1975 was it in
1973 was it one or offer of the
occasions when to call rejected I think
it was actually 1066 we're not
necessarily a half time on that one job
but the point is I mean you appreciate
that that whatever happens in two or
three years on the debate about
Britain's relationship with Europe is
going to be continuing and the second
point that you said you said nothing
changes if we stay in the EU well
unfortunately as you know given the way
that a EU works with with sort of more
and more powers being transferred by
successive treaties we've kind of seen
how that has happened over the years
that we've been a member of the EU and
even if there's a certain Euroskeptic
tension in numerous Member States we may
be slow to slow the process down that
you know again that this issue of
Britain's semi-detached relationship
with Europe by not being in the Euro by
not being in the Schengen zone and
frankly being unlikely to join either
even if we do remain somehow in the EU
how do you envisage I mean how do you
write to this idea of nothing changing
it seems to me that a lot of the
underlying tensions are going to remain
here and remain unresolved we don't we
don't have to join the Euro or Schengen
simple answer we don't have to join them
the fact that some of our European
partners have have set up a single
currencies is a matter for them we have
because of the brilliance of British
negotiations in times past including
John Major did a fantastic job at the
Maastricht Treaty we're not required to
join we we can choose as a country it's
very important not to scarify people
there is no treaty obligation on us what
so ever to join the Euro but we have a
right to join it if we wish to do so in
the future
my general point was even if we
nonetheless preserve the tensions that
we currently have
look what relationships in human affairs
do not involve tension I mean the whole
we're talking about a union between 28
nations which share our continent of
course that's going to be tense even if
the European Union works ten times
better that does at the moment you would
still have tension
this isn't whether there's tension
because there's inevitably going to be
tension in any relations of that kind
the question is whether it's manageable
and advantageous for us this is the
crucial point because you know there is
no perfection in human affairs is it
given the choice we face advantageous
and manageable for us to stay in the
European Union definitely it's
definitely advantageous it's definitely
manageable and do not scarify people
with phantoms which may or may not
emerge it may be that at some point in
the future we face another big issue in
our relation to the opinion about a
further act of integration it may it may
not we have faced them in the past and
we've managed to negotiate our way
through perfectly satisfactorily it's
perfectly satisfactory for there to be a
bloc of members of the European Union
that have a single currency and for us
not sue that is not a reason why we need
to give up free trade which is
essentially the big benefit that we have
inside the European Union at the moment
I'm not saying there won't be tension
but I do say that it's meant that that
tension is manageable and I certainly
think it's advantageous for us to stay
rather than to leave there was a
gentleman in the front row who was next
can I just say every battle of ideas
session I've been just someone has
complained about a lack of female voices
so if you're a woman please put your
hand up so we don't look sexist all
right so we'll go to you madam at some
point gentlemen down here at the front
row please case hi yeah thanks for a
great discussion Andrew you and I are
not going to persuade each other on
brick's it but in the spirit of
agreement on this Sunday morning I just
like to mention the I'm a big big fan of
HS to know our subject so basically my
question is when do you think it will
actually happen I know that you know and
how do you persuade the rest of the
country to get behind HST Oh
love to do a whole thinking session on
that the answer is it's happening at the
moment if you go in only a mile away
from here to Euston the whole of the
Houston area at the moment is one
massive building site because hs2 is
being constructed at the moment it's the
same in the center of Birmingham
so the issue isn't whether hs2 happens
the legislation has passed the money has
been allocated it is being built between
London and Birmingham the actual issue
there Boris is trying to elide it
because he's trying to appeal to people
who for land against in the way the boy
is always does he tries to appeal to
both sides by pretending he doesn't have
a view on either side well you can't
carry on doing that forever the issue
actually just isn't whether it's built
from London to Birmingham
it's whether you're going to stop it in
Birmingham now it would be ludicrous to
build a high-speed railway line which
goes halfway up the country you know it
obviously needs to go between the three
largest metropolitan centres the country
chooses its whole purpose which is
London Birmingham and Manchester the
fourth largest is lead such as the
reason why it should have a branch going
across there
my own view that the dynamic is such
that it will be built that way because
it will seem to the public to be so
ludicrous to have a high-speed line with
high capacity very fast journey times
night which stops in the Midlands so I
think it will happen what's at stake
really is whether we have an integrated
plan which were very bad doing an
overstretch an integrated plan in one go
to do London and Birmingham Manchester
Leeds or whether in classic British
fashion we half build it we get to
Birmingham we have a 20 year pause while
we have a massive national air about and
then we build it up to Manchester and
Leeds I think that that would be a
mistake and that's what I've been saying
very firmly personally actually because
I have a relationship with him Tobias is
that it's an absolute you can you could
have taken a decision for not to do it
just took I think that would've been a
mistake but to half build it and leave
people stranded in Birmingham on these
high-speed trains is that is the height
of folly I think we can all agree that
being stranded in Berman would be a
dreadful thing then would go to you
madam than to you madam and then to you
sir so leaving aside whether or not
leaving or remaining is a good or bad
thing one of the so-called advantages
that the leave campaign
and is that they were able to paint a
vision of how Britain could be better
whereas the remain campaign kind of
stuck with this status quo narrative and
how bad it would be if we left but the
fact is is that the status quo is not
going to stay the same it never has
stayed the same and the European Union's
got issues around a tax policy around
the stability of the euro an Army
foreign policy etc all of these things
that it wants to integrate and improve
upon and obviously we can all see the
trend that where the EU wants to be is
as a grand super state so why haven't
the remain campaign embraced that and
promoted the advantages and how great
that would be and how we could be a
global player because that is a
perfectly respectable position to have
but the reason why so many people don't
feel infused is because instead it's
adopted this position of or how terrible
that's going to be for the economy if we
leave so why not embrace that vision as
a super state Europe because I don't
agree with your premise that's the
reason why it's not correct I do I make
the argument for the European Union in
the way to Churchill made it in 1945 as
a kind of and the words kind of a
crucial a kind of United States of
Europe it's a kind of Federation and I
believe in that I believe in peace
prosperity very close partnership
including shared institutions between
the nations of Europe and actually in
the economic sphere those are highly
integrated we have the world's most
integrated and effective and largest
free trade and single market so indeed
in history no other group of 28
countries has managed to have not just
tariffs free but essentially regulation
free trade in the way we have now I
don't like the term super stakes it's
intended to be pejorative it is a quasi
Federation in the same way as because
there's no one standard form of
Federation for your studied political
sense a whole different sets of ways the
countries can work together at a
supranational level however does that
mean because that is a very successful
quasi Federation which is hugely boosted
the peace and prosperity of Europe
indeed in the case of peace largely
established it in the last 70 years that
therefore it TD logically if you know
using these sort of conceptual ways of
thinking about it
that must mean full integration in terms
of Armed Forces and a further big leap
forward in terms of of creating a single
economic policy for the whole of Europe
and all that the answers that's total
rubbish just take the issue of the
European army just to take that one as
one which is a kind of bogey there are
only two seriously functioning armies in
Europe
that's Britain and France we're the only
countries that spend enough on defense
and have a sufficiently large Armed
Forces to be able to mobilize
significant forces and indeed the one
that people save will be the linchpin of
this which is Germany if there were to
be European army Germany resolutely
refuses to invest more than a about a
much smaller proportion than we do of
their GDP on defense because they want
to spend it on other things now I know
Germany quite well I can assure you the
Chancellor Merkel and her likely
successors are not going to be leaping
to double German defense spending they
actually are quite happy piggybacking on
France Britain and the United States to
maintain their defense so it's it's
fairly important not to sort of believe
all this stuff that comes out of Nigel
Faraj and all of this that's because the
account European Union has certain
elements of a federation about it we're
therefore going to be having all of
these bogeymen it's not true as it
happens on the concept of a European
army on the concept of it I don't I
don't myself have a problem with it we
have a NATO army essentially at the
moment that's what how all everything we
do at the moment in terms of our
defenses based on NATO now NATO involves
a very very high degree of integration
between the forces of France Britain and
the United States including an article 5
of the NATO treaty and absolute
requirements to come to the defense of
all of the other members an attack on
one is an attack on all the loss of
sovereignty involved in that is much
greater than anything involved in the
European Union I don't have a problem
with it it works it's worked it's a it's
a club of democracies we share the same
values and all of that but in fact it's
not actually the case that we're going
to get a European army what's seriously
on the agenda because that isn't where
the politics of Europe is where is the
politics of Europe at the moment
it's seeking to maintain the peace and
stability of the existing European Union
which mean it means two things in
particular where we have a massive and
huge interest the first is seeing that
that the current European economic zone
functions effectively we have a huge
interest in that and the second to be
blunt is seeing that an out-of-control
semi fascist Russia which is on our
borders and is a real and present danger
to us it's already invaded one European
country to Ukraine it could easily
invade others that we keep them at bay
now the European Union together with
NATO have been have been doing a good
job of that over recent years we need to
sustain that we shouldn't be scary
fiying ourselves by a whole lot of
phantoms of things which which which are
simply not going to happen but which
could lead us to making big big mistakes
about withdrawing from existing areas of
integration and cooperation which are
working very effectively I couldn't
agree more
I think constant I don't think he's an
agent of President Putin and then we'll
go to you madam and then to you it was a
very strong labor seat but in recent
years I think people have got a bit fed
up with the arrogance of politicians in
fact some years ago when Hartlepool was
forced to have a mayoral election in the
monkey they elected the football
management among kings and of course in
the last election
well people very upset when Peter
Mandelson was parachuted in I mean he
did have some connections with the area
but of course he was a an outsider and
more recently they voted in the last
election a brexit candidate was elected
but even more than that in the last
local elections labour actually lost
control of the local authority and I
just wondered do you think it's
realistic of the Labour Party to think
that they can win
taxis seats with the promise of jump
tomorrow as you were saying a great
program of reforms and investment in
these poor poorer areas well I think
it's the only way isn't it because what
politics is about in a democracy is
seeking to deliver things that people
want and what people wanted hearted was
they want more investment and a serious
economic plan is the only way do I think
it's realistic to do it yes I think it
is realistic to do it and indeed there
you're absolutely right about what's
happened to Hartlepool you're completely
right that that labor did lose that the
local authority hasn't been strong
enough on the ground that's not true of
a lot of other communities in the in the
north where labor has remained very
strong you know for example the City of
Manchester there's a largest single
metropolitan area in the north there's
almost no non labor members of
Manchester City Council Andy Burnham is
the mayor of Greater Manchester there is
a sense of there being a proper plan for
Manchester including the area I'm most
interested in which is education and
transport you know Manchester is the
biggest and strongest University outside
London has more students apparently
anywhere west of Moscow so I'm bringing
these things in because of pranky
Constantine likes likes likes these
parallels and there's a big transport
ban all that so that the my view it and
part of the reason for that is labour
has had a good plan a reasonably good
plan for Greater Manchester including
creating a mayor a single integrated
Authority a big transport plan and all
that we haven't had a good enough plan
I'll be quite frank frank with you for
Hartlepool and some of the coastal
communities and we need to get much
better at that but when you say to what
do I think it's realistic yes I do think
it's realistic but also there's no
alternative because there's no other way
of rebuilding labour in these
communities rather than addressing what
are the real existing problems that they
face with with credible parents the
woman by the daughter yeah yes I think
the kind of the best thing really about
brexit is that it's kind of opened up a
lot of political questions that had been
really closed down for a generation
really so you mentioned already you know
united Ireland as Gibraltar but also
things like the House of Lords
first-past-the-post regional government
and you know I think that the the mood
of the country is not that they want any
kind of new system handed down to them
from government it feels like there's a
real desire and a real appetite for a
big process of democratic debates and
renewal and I just want Aleve well
that's right and if you think there's
any ways that we can you know foster
that I completely agree with that
but it doesn't require leaving the
European Union indeed you leaving the
European universe on for the House of
Lords I think the House of Lords isn't
that is at the moment is a democratic
monstrosity you know I mean I was
appointed by a prime minister fifteen
years ago and have no more legitimacy
than that I'm strongly in favor of an
elected House of House of Lords and I
was thinking should have a strong
regional component and should help to
bring the nations and the regions of the
country together a bit like the second
chambers in in in Germany in the United
States so I certainly do
I think it's right to open up those
issues I think we need much stronger
devolution we need to hand a lot lot
more power down to local governments and
regional and city governments in England
because England is essentially run
almost like a colony from London at the
moment we need to reform second chamber
all of those things I think are correct
and you may be right the BRICS has had
the effects the brexit argument has had
the effect of opening them up in a
bigger way than before I would I would
accept that but I don't think they might
think it is to leave the European Union
I think the right thing to do is to stay
in the European Union but address those
issues and it's a wake up call to the
political class that they do need to be
addressed I mean you know House of Lords
reform has been on the agenda for a
century and it we never actually managed
to do any of it it's about time we
actually got real and did it
a gentleman in the middle er I've been a
Labour voter all my life I won't be
voting labour in this coming up election
and the reason is purely down to
leadership will show say lack of
leadership the whole Briggs is issued
with Corbin and the anti-semitism is
unbelievably can't get that right in his
own party I genuinely don't see how he
could ever lead a country my question to
you is if we had somebody like say Kier
stammered
leading labour now
do you think the polls the whole
dynamics of this situation would be in a
completely different place well I I care
as a friend of mine I think he'd make an
excellent leader of the Labour Party but
you can only have one leader at a time
and we are in a general election
campaign at the moment and the choice
which faces the country it's a real
choice is do you want as the Prime
Minister on the 13th of December Boris
Johnson with all that comes with him or
Jeremy Corbyn my judgement is the rules
pretty clear on aren't they the real
poll is on the 12th of my friend here
was asking me saying you know and that
that is the choice that we face my
judgement is that the better thing for
the country the better policy for the
country the better leader out of those
two and that's the choice that we face
is it would be Jeremy Corbyn do I think
in due course Kirstin would make a great
leader of the Labour Party
I completely agree he would this is the
biggest open goal that we've ever seen
the one thing you can't do in any
situation is to say I wish we weren't
here because we done five things
differently in the past you know I wish
we done five things differently in the
past but we are where we are the choice
facing the country now in an election
which is now underway that is the choice
and we all have to make judgments on
that basis that is the choice which the
country faces and given the both the
people involved and the policies which
underlie those people too I think that
the right the right government for the
country on the 13th of December would be
a Labour led government not not a toy
led government and this issue of brexit
is absolutely central to that do we have
anybody else yes
so I know if we could pass it down to
the man in the Hat Jared hello thanks
very much I'm really fascinated by one
of the points that you made earlier on
concerning what's actually inside the
brexit debate I took on organizing
London intellectual dark web group
because I wanted to meet people who were
across the aisle from me I found over
this a 10 years since I got a smartphone
in 2009 that I abandoned my habit of
reading lots of different news
newspapers and when I fine was talking
with people across the aisle is that the
idea of bricks that has become
superordinate and the discussion on any
other issues to do with housing
transport and all the other issues
really faded in the background
a few months ago I started asking people
would they rather we left the European
brexit ears but they rather we leave the
European Union or would we rather have
the time and effort spent in dealing
with housing or trans-border all all the
other issues and I've really been
astonished that they're not that there's
not that they haven't thought about it
but they they're they're astonished that
there could be an alternative to take up
a political time outside outside of
brexit why is it that you that you think
that the brexit issue has become so
superordinate taking up everything that
all of these other issues that actually
inform it such as austerity have been
sort of largely abandoned in the
background because in it real in a real
existing in the real existing situation
it is I like that like though which I
haven't used before but we need another
word for this Sunday more anything
superordinate I've never used that word
like I take super ordinate to mean
overwhelming yeah well it but the reason
why people are treating it as an
overwhelming issue is because it is an
overwhelming issue you know the European
Union withdrawal app which is one of
nine nine pieces of legislation which
are needed to prepare the way for
leaving the European Union that's before
we get to these trade deals and
everything else coming down the line
that was debated in the House of Commons
and the House of Lords for 300 hours
which is longer than any piece of
legislation has been debated in the
history of Parliament so when you say
that the issue is superordinate and
people treat it as if it's superordinate
the reason they treat it as if it's
super ordinate is because it is super
ordinate how much time is Parliament
spent debating housing policy in the
last three years
well I we had a debate in the House of
Lords on housing two weeks ago the
debate lasted two hours those are the
relative ratios of the time Parliament
is spending until Parliament's itself
which is our political class and our
political institutions themselves
couldn't find a way of moving on we are
going to be overwhelmed and
unfortunately also has the effect which
I think has been deeply damaging to our
politics but which you were so hinting
at in your remarks which is that every
other issue is seen through the prism of
brexit now let me say I think that is a
complete mistake as part of reason I'm
so much against BRICS it
brixon the reason the way of dealing
with the housing crisis is hey presto to
deal with the housing crisis its to
start building castle houses again in a
big way it's to starting into the
business of regulating the private
rented sector is to give people a fair
deal it's to end the - child policy
which is monstrous inside Universal
Credit that means a lot of people can't
even afford decent quality housing at
all that's the way you deal with it it's
not by somehow doing brexit because then
it's going to I don't know what you know
the chain of argue which then goes on is
then we're going to give a wake-up call
to the political classes what my friend
they said a few moments ago and all that
hinting it's going to do it won't what
it will do is bricks it will lead to
more directs it because as I said once
you've got your first installment of
bricks you then got your 10 years of
trade negotiation that so you'll get
even less housing policy so what I am
trying to do with lots of other people
in politics at the moment is to stop
this this paradigm so we're using all
these long these words day this paradigm
which comes to see all the issues facing
the country in the context of whether we
do or don't leave the European Union
what we should do is to not do that and
instead address directly all of these
other issues and my view is if we done
that first time round because this was
the fundamental mistake made by Cameron
because Cameron himself who put this
right at the center of politics if
instead we puts housing the NHS
education inequality apprenticeships all
of those issues which fundamentally
affect the whole future of the country
we put those at the center of politics
we wouldn't be having this debate about
the superordinate issue of bricks in the
first place okay we can take one more
question from the gentleman over there
with his hand up yes this is my friend
socially yes intent on thinking that I
am in a fundamentally different tribe
from him well I think I think you've
been great today I might say but I just
like to ask what you think now in light
of experience and so forth about your
Academy schools education policy was it
radical enough because now let's talk
about you know labor going on to
abolishing the public schools getting
rid of Eaton personally I'm all in
favor of greater equality in society
this is what but but you know this is
question of sort of whether you should
build people up or destroy things down
and I don't like personally the idea of
destroying Eton how do you how do you
feel about this were your what's your
earlier policy radical enough or is the
prospective one maybe too radical look
coming back because this is the
fundamentalist suit you're dealing with
in in the public service at the moment
is austerity or not a stove a and it
really comes into sharp relief when you
look at the issue of education there
were some elements to the cadmus posit
which is controversial in the Labor
Party they were to do with how you run
schools and I'll come back to those in a
moment but the biggest elements of the
Academy program the biggest element by
far was massive investment in state
education the academies program was part
of a program which was called building
schools to the future which was
investing in the rebuilding renewal of
every school in the country it was very
bold which when we left office in 2010
was eight billion pounds a year when I
first started working for Tony Blair in
1998 and we got going on this serious
education policy we were spending as a
country eight hundred million a year on
the building and renewal of school
building so we in that labor government
increased by tenfold tenfold the
national spending on on school buildings
now my own view is there's nothing more
important in a society and the quality
of its schools that is what you know
renews a society and nurtures the next
generation we should be spending
properly on school buildings one of the
biggest things that happen with
austerity was a cut in the school
building program it was cut immediately
from eight billion to three billion and
it's now running under two billion a
year that is the difference of Labor
government makes and what austerity has
meant now we've said were we radical
enough the academies policy that the
controversial bit of the academies
policy which was essentially closing
seriously failing schools and reopening
them with new leadership that's what
essentially it was was always
controversial wasn't involved change and
for and for some of the people who being
responsible for running the previous
school of course it was controversial
with them but actually you know the
proof of the pudding is in the eating
those schools have been
nominally successful those of you who
live in communities which have got the
original academies that were set up
schools like Moss born in Hackney I
could go down the list there very very
few people who'd want to move back to
what we had before were we radical
enough no what I wanted to move on soon
I see is the next big issue in education
is what happens to people who don't go
to university because in our country at
the moment people go to university get a
pretty good deal there are controversies
there about tuition fees and all that
but other less we have first-rate
universities people do well they have
higher earning power we have a terrible
apprenticeship system in this country we
don't have a proper system of training
and career development for the 60% of 18
year olds 60% who don't go to university
and the thing I was desperate to move on
to in 2010 was to try and create a wait
for it because with some of my people
who don't like Europe you won't like
this but I'm going to say anyway to
create in Britain an apprenticeship
system like the Germans because the
Germans have a fantastic the Germans the
Germans and the dart is not just the
Germans the Germans have a brilliant
apprenticeship system which invests as
much in 18 year-olds who don't go to
university as those who do that's the
next big and bold new frontier I want it
and I still think we need to be doing it
and just to wrap up on these remarks if
we weren't doing bricks and I could get
back to things I really love which is
partly transport I'm a bit of a trade
nerd I'm afraid but also education those
are the things I'd be doing and we need
to put them right at the center of
debate you know the proposition I'd like
to put before people is why is it that
we do not in this country spend as much
on every 19 year old who doesn't go to
university as those who do go to
university at the moment we spent four
times more on those who do go to
university than those who don't
surprise surprise where do we get big
disaffection people don't have decent
earning power people who are disaffected
it's by and large and those who don't
get the opportunity to go to university
that's what we should be sorting out as
a country not this absolutely terrible
off the edge of a cliff brexit business
which is making it even harder for us to
deal with housing build hs2 by the way
the No Deal preparations alone would
have built half of my hs2 line alone you
know all of these contracts with ferry
companies that they'd have various all
of that
so stop exit
old HS to build houses deal with the
education crisis have a proper
apprenticeship system and then we'd be
much much better off as a country lurid
honest I love how in the question about
education you went from education to
apprenticeship to breaks it to HSN back
to the trains you've covered everything
very very quickly literally in ten
seconds the last question we always ask
on trigonometry is what's the one thing
that no one's talking about that we
should be talking about actually it's
housing at the moment we have a housing
crisis greater than any time in the last
50 years we have people living millions
of people millions of people in this
country our fellow citizens living in
slum conditions at the moment that is an
absolute scandal at the heart of our
society and if there's one thing we sort
out in the next ten years it should be
that fantastic I think we can all agree
Lord of Darkness has been absolutely
brilliant please give him a round of
applause thanks was great it was great
with you and I promise if I become
transport sector gain I am sorting out
those problems on the m25 thank you so
much
subscribe to us wonder will to use your
channels you've been absolutely
brilliant um and enjoy the rest of the
battle of ideas see again bye thank you
bye bye
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word